Speaker 1: All right.
Why don't we speak next to let's speak to
let's go international.
Let's speak to Karl from Stockholm.
Karl from Stockholm, are you on?
Are you unmuted, can you hear me?
Speaker 4: Hmm.
Speaker 1: All right, that's too bad, I was
hoping to speak to Karl, let's go to Schizo
from North Carolina.
You're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Awesome, pleasure to speak to you.
I found your show not too long ago.
I have a couple of questions I have been dealing
with.
So I'm kind of a little nervous, but I've
been dealing with my fiancee who is buying
into all of these conspiracies that are going
around, and basically she has put an ultimatum
in.
The relationship, she's basically said that
if I get vaccinated, it would be the end of
our relationship and it's.
It's really stressing me out because I'm constantly
like researching and finding that the the
claims of conspiracy theorists don't hold
water.
That's right.
When you actually.
Do the research, that's correct.
So but the problem is I've seen her go from
being completely afraid of this when it first
started and then attaching.
To these conspiracies.
As a way to cope with the fear that she was
Speaker 1: having, that's very common.
That's very common.
People would rather take solace in that.
The conspiracy, which suggests that we have
much more control over things than we actually
have.
It's scary that this might be an out of control
pandemic.
So folks would rather believe whatever conspiracy
theory about the virus or the vaccine, that's
very common.
Speaker 4: Yeah, the problem I'm finding myself
in is because I, I, I haven't gotten vaccinated
yet and I really do want to because I have
basically I have a one year old child and.
I'm not willing to take the risk that I won't
be here for him,
Speaker 1: and that makes a lot of sense.
Speaker 4: But for her, it's not bad for her,
it's it seems that if I do so, it's almost
like a religious belief where it offends her,
that it will be the end of our relationship.
And basically, it's boiled down to if I do
this, I am a stupid person for falling into
this whole thing.
So do you have any recommendations?
Speaker 1: Well, that's right.
I can't tell.
So let me ask you a couple of questions.
Is this is this the mother of the one year
old you just mentioned?
Yes, it is.
OK, and how long have you been together?
Speaker 4: About three, three years now and
do
Speaker 1: you do you want to continue together?
Speaker 4: Yes, absolutely.
OK, well, I'm willing to.
To.
To stick around, because I also am afraid
of the issues that will happen if I'm no longer
in the relationship and what she'll do in
order to keep me away from my son,
Speaker 1: that's a scary thing.
That's a scary I mean, listen, I'm going to
I'm going to I don't know the full situation.
And ultimately you have to decide.
But let me ask you this.
Have you thought about just getting vaccinated
and not telling her and not talking about
it?
Speaker 4: Yes.
Yes, that has been my conclusion.
This past day or two.
I actually talked to a friend and he said,
listen, I know it sucks, but maybe that's
just the thing to do.
The only.
So I've I figured that that's probably the
best option for me.
But now I've thought of what am I going to
do when I get my vaccination card, because
we're going to be going to we're going to
be going out of town soon.
And there's I find I think I try to think
of head and wallet.
Will there be a situation where we are we
aren't going to be allowed to do something
unless we we show our vaccination card and,
you know, I'm going to be vaccinated.
But she's not.
Speaker 1: And well, I mean, basically, you
would just if you want to keep it secret,
you would just have to be like if there's
a she's not going to be allowed to do that
thing anyway.
So then maybe you're just both not doing that
thing and you don't need to worry about it.
Just just go.
You'll be vaccinated, but you can go out and
do your unvaccinated life with her.
I mean, I agree that it sucks, but if the
priority is you think it could be a really
bad situation for your child.
And so you want to I it's really hard for
me to give serious, you know, to seriously
give advice because I don't know the full
situation, but my immediate mind goes to at
least get yourself vaccinated and just don't
mention it so that you are less likely to
get the virus and spread it to her.
Speaker 4: I, I that's kind of what I've come
to.
There's only just one question I have left
and it's I want to get vaccinated, but I want
to not give it away that I'm vaccinated by
having any side effects.
So I don't know what you recommend.
Speaker 1: Oh, you just say you're feeling
under the weather.
I mean the the side effects you would have
would be sort of like feeling a little bit
cold or flu like.
So you just say I'm a little I've got a cold,
you know.
Speaker 4: OK, yeah.
You said you got vaccinated.
You get the.
Which one did you get.
I got Moderna.
Oh, sorry, cut off, I can't hear.
OK.
Speaker 1: All right, Schizo's sounds complicated.
Sounds like we're having a connection issue,
so I'm going to let you go.
But that's that's a tough situation.
That's a tough situation.
All right, guys, I've taken all the calls
I can take today.
We will take calls again very soon.